hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my Facebook reader Syed who wants to
start a new ice cream business and
wanted my advice on how to get started
and we had a couple questions so
specifically is asking about Facebook
how to advertise on Facebook if it's
worth setting up a website or a brand
page on Facebook what do I think about
partnering up with shops or creating the
shop in a university college or shopping
mall and how do you promote the the
company so thanks to the questions I had
I think it's a very common question a
lot of entrepreneurs face when they're
starting a new business and so hopefully
we can answer questions that a lot of
entrepreneurs are facing right now in
terms of the Facebook thing I think it's
a good idea to have a Facebook page for
your company it's really easy to set up
you don't need to have a lot of
technical skills and a lot of
entrepreneurs are using that instead of
having their own website just because
it's so easy to set up and they can
manage everything themselves that may
not be an ideal kind of long-term
situation but a lot of entrepreneurs
will launch with just a Facebook page
and then as you're making money you're
able to afford going out and getting a
designer and creating your own website
I'm a big believer in not spending a lot
of money until I'm making money so this
is a great way to do it if you just
create a Facebook page doesn't cost you
anything you make a quick banner and you
start promoting your business before you
actually go up launch your site now in
terms of the Facebook ads that can be
really tough because it's really hard to
make direct sales to Facebook ads the
Facebook community is more about
building relationships and getting
people interested in what you're doing
and then hopefully after they've you
know built that relationship with you
they end up buying whatever product or
service you're having but for you know
just to advertise your ice cream product
you're probably not going to make a lot
of money off of Facebook Ads directly
your better bet is to promote your page
have a lot of great content have some
fun things that make people want to come
back and of course also promote your ice
cream products and so it's a longer term
commitment with anything else I like
testing things so try it out see if it
works you know commit a minimum or
maximum budget I guess to it and see if
your
optimal with that so you can say 100
bucks 200 bucks 500 bucks dude if you're
comfortable with but don't go you know
too far beyond because it's easy to to
spend a lot of money right anybody can
spend money and I want to make sure
you're you're the entrepreneur can
actually make money doing this I think
with any new entrepreneur venture it's
really important to test on a small
scale to see if what you have is a
really good idea or not I don't know why
I chose the ice cream business hopefully
it's because you have a strong passion
for ice cream and you think you can
really make a go out of it in it and
it's not just something to try and make
a lot of money
we recently post on our website at a
profile of Ben & Jerry's from there the
ice cream Ben and Jerry and they started
from a five dollar ice cream making
corpse and they launched out of an old
gas station so I might be an
inspirational story for you to read but
I think for you to get started what I
would try to do is partner up I think
that's your best bet right now be able
to see if it works and start getting
access to potential customers so I don't
the idea is that you mentioned I think
your best bet would be to try to get
into the universities colleges shopping
malls but don't do it by getting your
own stall that can be really expensive
and you're blowing again a lot of money
and you don't know if it's going to work
out or not what I would try to do is
partner up with somebody who's already
there and try to get a portion of their
table maybe for a day a week month
weekends whatever it is whenever you
think you know you would probably get
some customers coming in partner up with
them you can either give them ideally
just a cut of the revenue but you may
have to give them a set fee but it's
going to be a lot cheaper to do that on
a one offer or two off or three offers
you test it then to try to get your own
booth for a month or quarter or year
it's going to be really expensive so
that way you can test it see if that
market works to you or not and if it
does then you can say hey this makes
sense for me to get my own booth and if
it doesn't then you haven't wasted a lot
of money needlessly so it's really
important to test on a small scale so
you'll find somebody who is also selling
to those markets see if you can strike
up some kind of partnership and from
there you will discover if that is your
target market or not and if people are
willing to buy your ice cream products
right so good luck and hopefully that
answer some of your questions for you
because as you're watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes you want to do more of
these videos for you guys
and if you have a question that I can
answer for your business or a comment
about the video feel free to leave it in
the comments below I always read those
and try to respond to as many as it can
so thank you and you'll see you on the
next episode
you
you